[Music]
good Lord in heaven Rocky City wow
what'd they used to call it the crown
jewel of Florida
okay oh I got the crown part right
pretty goddamn accurate
[__] man I was goddamn handsome back
when I moseyed into Rocky fixing to take
the whole town by storm hey Casey lordy
Lord here looking Dynamite why thanks
the blues come in yet you know the
little ones with my hat on them those
pills ship in tonight we'll be good to
go well I think it's time that we giddy
up all righty okay
you're being attacked by whom
rappers don't you lose my candy gun
damn it
do not let it happen
[__] that's a lot of them
take them all down
foreign
yeah yeah
[Music]
what is the situation
expected
what the [__] happened sir the blues and
all the truck
candy was taken and it was this [__]
yellow who case he told me about a Rival
Dealer in the party scene yellow yeah
yellow don't [__] correct me yeah get
it back before Dawn
foreign